well what else is there to talk about
the Grand Theft Auto 6 League how did it
happen what was in it what is Rockstar's
response here's everything you need to
know about the biggest League the gaming
industry has ever seen
now before we get into this I just want
to be expressly clear nothing you are
about to see is from the new GTA game
okay Rockstar's legal team if you're
listening and I've heard that they're
big fans of this show we're not showing
any screenshots any gameplay nothing not
a zip zilch got it okay good here we go
so how did the league happen on Sunday
September 20th a user that goes by the
name of teapot tuber hacker posted on
gtaforms.com over 90 clips of
in-development footage of the game they
claimed that the clips were taken from
Rockstar's internal slack which also
allowed them to get their hands on
source code for the game The Hacker
updated their post later that day
directing any employees of Rockstar or
take 2 interactive to contact them via
email as they were quote looking to
negotiate a deal there has been no
update as of this recording from the
hacker so what was released well a
metric ton the footage in 90 plus Clips
totaled a near hour of incomplete GTA 6
gameplay the validity of the footage
before Rockstar could confirm the leak
came in the form of two key details that
lined up with Bloomberg's report earlier
this year about the game one all the
gameplay took place in Vice City Grand
Theft Auto's Miami parody and the
location of the game according to
Bloomberg's report that report also
included the detail that the player
would take control of two characters a
man and a woman whom are meant to be a
Bonnie and clyde-like pairing the
gameplay seen in the league featured
both a playable man and woman pop-up
text during the footage refers to the
man as Jason and the woman as Lucia
Jesus Christ that's Jason the footage
showed off the character's abilities to
crouch go prone and move while doing
both going prone is something that can't
be done in GTA 5 and the only way to
crouch in that game is by taking cover
behind a low profile object both of
these elements hint that playing
stealthily might be a viable course of
action in the game particularly as the
footage also reveals a mechanic to pick
up bodies that you could then presumably
hide Lucia is seen carrying a duffel bag
with a number of inventory slots as well
as there being animations for picking up
weapons which are displayed as being
strapped to the character's bodies when
not carried in their hands these
elements hint toward GTA 6 getting a
similar inventory system to Red Dead
Redemption 2 where players will be
limited by what they can carry and will
have to pick and choose which weapons to
take with them also similar to rdr2 are
the contextual menus while targeting
NPCs in that game locking onto an NPC
offered several options such as greeting
them or robbing them in the leaked GTA 6
footage options to Rob restrain melee
and surrender are shown speaking of NPCs
one of the clips features a conversation
between two of them commenting on events
from GTA 5 so that almost guarantees
this game takes place either during or
after the current release hovercrafts
are shown off vehicles that haven't been
present in the series since GTA San
Andreas and according to video game
Insider Tom Henderson from a now deleted
tweet thousands of lines of the source
code make mention of jet packs and
finally the game seems to feature a
parody of the popular WhatsApp messaging
service that the game will call what up
considering how many of GTA 5's menus
were handled via an in-game smartphone
and how far that Tech has come since
that game's release it's not hard to
imagine that GTA 6's smartphone will be
even more robust and tightly integrated
okay so what does Rockstar have to say
about all this the developer confirmed
the leak was the result of a quote
Network intrusion it also made the
reassuring comment that it does not
anticipate any disruption to the
development of the game a major concern
many had when the leak happened over the
weekend Rockstar capped the message off
by stating that it would show off the
game when it is ready to be shown off
and that's it everything you need to
know about the GTA 6 leak what do you
think of some of the mechanics we
mentioned today let us know in the
comments below and we'll see you here
tomorrow for more Gamespot news
[Music]